I owe my life to running I go my
resurrection to running because of
running I've been able to come out in a
new trajectory I wanted to raise a
national awareness campaign around
missing and murdered indigenous women
my face paint is is your typical warrior
stoic look of course they have the the
blood-stained blood here representing
all the bloodshed of our women and
that's what I wanted to capture I wanted
to address all the bloodshed out there
and so that's why i wavered on my face
it's a very very powerful statement
I'm the only one that's doing this
amount of awareness on a national scale
so more and more people are learning
about it and wanting to take part in it